we do have a voicemail number it is
available to you 24 hours a day the
number is 219 to david p
you can call anytime
some people leave 20 voicemails in a row
and typically when that happens they
just get deleted we we don't have the
ability to field that much material but
here is someone who called in
who has a prediction about merrick
garland the midterms and charges against
donald trump take a listen this is
jonathan in los angeles please i believe
merrick garland is going to wait until
after the midterms to a lump
to
indict trump and his cronies
to avoid any
appearance of being political
and when which case we're going to have
a huge
huge
case of uh
special elections across the country
i i don't see that as likely and
there are some folks emailing me about
trump indictments where it's starting to
sound a little bit like this i don't
mean this to be insulting but it's sort
of like the trump people who were saying
okay before december 13th this thing's
gonna be overturned
well it's gonna be before january 6th
it'll be by the inauguration it'll be by
march april early summer late summer
halloween thanksgiving
and like it's just not gonna happen
um i don't think merrick garland is
waiting for the midterms to indict trump
and his cronies i just don't i've seen
no evidence of that
uh and
unless you know joe biden's not running
for reelection i mean either way
i think there's also a risk politically
to doing it after the midterms anyway
so i just don't see that as a likely
scenario but i would love to be wrong
and i'm willing to have my mind changed
by the facts changing on the ground
we have a tremendous bonus show for you
today we are going to talk about the
average workday work from home higher
than ever during the pandemic
work day length
longer than ever during the pandemic on
average people are working an extra full
hour a day
we'll talk about it
elon musk
has changed his mind or twitter has elon
musk after buying a seven percent stake
in twitter will not be joining the
twitter board and we will also talk
about a bill introduced by democrats
which would require employees be given
time off to vote
um some folks thought maybe you had that
already but not in this way so we're
going to talk about all of those stories
on today's bonus show i also want to
remind you david pakman show town hall
one week from today 6 p.m eastern on
april 19th it'll be streaming live on
the pacman live youtube channel that's
not the main youtube channel that's the
other youtube channel pacmanlive
everybody is welcome to participate and
lastly you can now gift memberships
at
joinpakman.com if you have a membership
already great
we have almost 700 people waiting for
free memberships you can sign up and
check that this is a gift box and we'll
give a membership to someone who's
waiting join pacman.com place to do it
we'll see you on the bonus show or
otherwise i'll see you back here
tomorrow